yeah all right thank you yeah so last
time I spoke here the Symons Institute I
talked about quantum algorithms for
chemistry within error correction so
this time we're going to the far extreme
of the quantum chemistry and qualm
computers field and actually talking
about an experiment on this device so
I'm going to start with just some
overall context about where we are today
with quantum computing I think most of
you are probably on the same page with
this but we're in the Niska era this
means we have noise in our circuits
maybe we can do circuits on about 50
cubits or something but we're severely
limited in the size of circuits we can
perform last year our team at Google
demonstrated this quantum super MC
milestone which means that there's at
least some contrived computational task
that we can solve on our device which
would be in practice and feasible to
perform on the classical supercomputer
but this doesn't mean that we're you
know about to start solving useful
applications on our device necessarily
so the ultimate goal of our group is to
build an aircraft at quantum computer
and certainly many of the quantum
algorithms that are discussed at this
conference and you know sort of the
vision of quantum computing that we have
in our dreams would require this of
course you know quantum error correction
has very large resource overheads and we
can sort of think of this in terms of
the number of qubits so for thinking
about implementing the surface code with
aerates similar to what we've
demonstrated in experiment then up to
about 50 cubits you could classically
simulate the circuit the quantum
supremacy experiment shows were sort of
just beyond that threshold but to start
doing useful things as far as we know
within the surface code on a
fault-tolerant quantum computer you're
probably going to need hundreds of
thousands of physical qubits at these
error rates so we have a road map
together we're very serious about
getting there but it's going to take a
while and we're gonna have devices that
are smaller than that in the mean time
so you know it's sort of worthwhile to
ask are these devices in the meantime
going to be able to do anything useful
and that's sort of the activity of
seeing what we can do with this devices
so I'm gonna quickly review the kalam
chemistry problem because this talk is
about doing quantum chemistry so the
goal is to solve for the energy of a
molecule molecules have protons and
electrons they're interacting with the
Coulomb operator they have kinetic
energy
and you've seen this curve now a couple
times this one drum you know behind me
but it's the binding curve for a
molecule you know there's one degree of
freedom here so we're solving for the
energy of the electronic wave function
and energy services like this they allow
us to understand chemical reactions but
we need fairly high precision in order
to do that in order to predict chemical
reaction rates so you know garnet
gave a talk earlier about sort of where
classical methods for quantum chemistry
are and he's certainly correct that you
can do sort of more than you might
expect with quantum meth or classical
methods but especially for systems with
strong correlation there are plenty of
examples where it's achieving the level
of accuracy we need to predict rates and
mechanisms is quite challenging on
classical devices and so these are sort
of the systems that we think about
solving on quantum computers so finally
I should say that to represent the wave
function on a quantum computer we have
to you know confine it to some basis so
usually we're thinking of a basis of
orbitals like molecular orbitals shown
here and we're usually working in second
quantization so for instance if we have
four orbitals which are places that
electrons could be and we'll have four
qubits and each qubit represents one of
those orbitals it's one if there's an
electron there and it's zero if it isn't
so there's you know you sort of everyone
sort of loves applying these variational
quantum algorithms to chemistry and this
is actually a fairly small sample of the
experiments have been published that
there are actually experiments computing
binding curves for molecules on real
processors so this is probably maybe 1/4
of what's been published so far they've
done an ion traps on photonic devices on
superconducting qubits but it's worth
noting that the largest of these
experiments have been performed are on
only up to 6 cubits so you know you can
be kind of confused about what molecules
people are solving sometimes people say
they're solving the water molecule or a
benzene molecule and really they're just
simulating 3 electrons on it or
something but you know the first order
the number of qubits being used is a
pretty good measure of how big the
experiment is and the fact that we've
only seen these experiments up to 6
cubits that's an indication that these
experiments are quite challenging
and we'll talk a bit more about those
challenges but it should sort of give us
pause that you know it's we've only done
these experiments up to six cubits so
what is the point really of doing these
application experiments on this devices
at all so there's a couple cynical
reasons you could throw out there so one
of them is that you know it's definitely
easier to publish these experiments in
nature than most of our theory work
that's a very bad reason of course so
another reason I think this is actually
kind of a serious reason is that it's
often I think a good thing to sort of
force algorithm mists like us who work
on algorithms to you know actually feel
the pain of a real experiment which can
be pretty substantial
you know you learned that there's
there's a lot more that you need to do
to sort of get performance out of the
device than you would think you know if
you're not using a qubit for a while
it's the best thing just to apply
identity they're probably not you should
probably be applying spin echoes like X
gates how often should you do that
there's lots of little tricks like this
which are good to learn but I think
another reason is that you know to some
extent we can sort of disagree over you
know whether we should be focusing on
benchmarking our devices with randomized
benchmarking or cross-entropy
benchmarking or quantum volume or
something
but these application experiments that
you know a lot of people are trying to
do I think it provides something of sort
of a system level benchmark you know how
what sort of qualm chemistry experiments
can you do on an ion trap or a
superconducting qubit system I think
it's telling that at this point we've
done four times larger quantum chemistry
simulations on superconducting qubits
than on ion traps and not for lack of
people trying on ion traps so to some
extent I think that these experiments
helped us sort of compare where our
devices relativity competitors but
probably more importantly if we ever
think that NIST devices might be useful
for solving you know actual applications
like in chemistry you know maybe it's
apparent that the particular methods
that we're using today aren't quite
there we need to develop better error
mitigation techniques or something like
this but it would be useful to know you
know exactly how far away are we from
doing something that's really
interesting or weird five cubits or 10
cubits or
25 cubits and so sort of a way of
measuring our progress towards improving
these methods and the devices I think
perhaps the most important reason though
is simply to sort of study the effects
of air mitigation techniques because
this is something which is very
difficult to do in simulation you often
don't actually know you know good models
for the noise affecting your devices and
it's kind of a parent that for Niska
algorithms air mitigations essential so
the best way to tell how those things
are actually working is to just try them
out all right so what experiment did we
actually perform it's maybe not the
experiment that a lot of people were
expecting the first chemistry experiment
on this device to be but it's one I'll
spend a while sort of explaining the
justification for it is a variational
algorithm as I'm sure no one is too
surprised by that but the on sauce that
we use in the variational algorithm is
actually a non Tots that corresponds to
changing the single particle basis that
we're using to represent the wave
function so if we started with you know
orbitals like the ones that I've drawn
here the unit area that we're going to
apply it changes the basis such that
we're now in a new basis which can be
written as an orthogonal linear
combination of this old faces and the
unitary that this corresponds to has a
very simple form it's not an obvious
form that you would have this
correspondence but it's due to something
called the Thewlis theorem essentially
so basically these arbitrary basis
rotations can be expressed as a unitary
that's generated by evolution under a
free fermion hamiltonian and so this is
what this basis rotation would look like
where these Kappa values have the
relation I've written here to the
coefficients of the actual basis change
so when you you know use this on sauce
in a variational algorithm and then you
optimize the parameters you're actually
applying what chemists would refer to as
the hartree-fock procedure which is a
mean field algorithm for you know
approximating the ground state energy
and this is actually so one way to think
about this is actually usually this
algorithm is run is a way of computing
these orbitals so if we think about what
we're doing here we're starting in some
product state essentially and we're
applying this unitary which I've
described here we can actually think of
this just as a basis rotation on the
Hamiltonian and we're essentially
solving for the parameters of that basis
rotation which allows sort of a product
state to express the lowest possible
energy in other words we're solving for
the lowest energy basis for the system
and of course this procedure is
completely classically tractable usually
it's the starting point for at least
quantum algorithms or chemistry so why
are we doing that in a quantum computer
and to be clear we're not getting a
speed-up over what a classical algorithm
would do here either so there's a couple
reasons I'll get into this one a bit
more but first these basis rotations are
a fairly ubiquitous primitive and
quantum simulation I'll argue that
they're sort of essential for many of
the best algorithms we have for
simulating chemistry or Hubbard models
or things like this on the quantum
computer so it's a primitive we're going
to want to apply anyways and learning
how to do it well is by itself sort of
valuable and also it's a primitive for
which we have a compilation which is
known to be optimal which I'll discuss
too which is kind of nice and because of
these things I think it makes sort of a
great benchmark so to the extent that
we're interested in you know sort of
comparing how different platforms are
doing for qualm chemistry I think this
you know achieves that goal the other
thing is that while it's a state that
has some structure which allows us to
solve for it classically from the
perspective of the quantum bits it's a
very entangled state if I just sort of
gave you this state you'd have a
difficult time telling that it you know
it's not some very complicated state the
structure and it's sort of hitting and
this is actually very much a feature of
the experiment because I won't have too
much time to get into this but in the
paper that we'll have out fairly soon we
sort of discussed that this structure
gives us a lot of insight into how
errors are affecting the system so for
instance we can efficiently compute the
fidelity of the state that we're
preparing without doing tomography or we
can exactly compute what the systematic
errors were in the circuits that we
applied in things like this and also as
I'll mention briefly the structure of
this particular choice somewhat
simplifies the implementation that we
face okay so why am I so obsessed with
basis or
and I think this is such an important
thing to practice doing so you know when
you write down the kalam chemistry
Hamiltonian in the normal molecular
orbital basis you get this very
complicated object which has end of the
four terms in it and that complicates
you know the number of measurements you
have to make and BQE that complicates
the number of gates would be in a
Trotter step it complicates a lot of
things so you know one comment is that
if you use a simpler basis for instance
you know these sinc functions or
something which are related to plane
waves you can get a much simpler form of
the Hamiltonian that has only n squared
terms in it and so you know Hamiltonian
like this which is you know expressed
using this basis you can perform
measurements much easier
the Trotter steps are much smaller there
are some downsides of a basis like this
namely it's less compact so you will
often need more qubits to represent the
system but often it's still a good
trade-off and if you want to use a basis
like this that's great the Hamiltonian
is simpler but the state you start in
which is a product state is now going to
be you know a product state in this
basis which has probably very little
overlap with the ground state you'd
rather you know start in a state that's
a product state in this basis and so the
first thing you have to do is you have
to apply a basis rotation in order to
rotate yourself into the correct basis
if you're going to perform any
simulation you know in a simple basis
like this also to actually perform
something like the Trotter step here
probably one of the more sensible
strategies in fact the strategy which as
far as we can tell has the least Trotter
error for simulating this Hamiltonian
consists of first simulating this
potential term which is diagonal and
then applying the basis rotation to
diagonalize the one body operator and
then applied that where it's diagonal
and then switching back so the Trotters
step would also involve basis rotations
finally and Brigitta touched on this
briefly in the end of her talk if you
don't want to make this trade-off where
you lose compactness in the
representation of the Hamiltonian you
don't want to use plane waves that's
fine you can take this Hamiltonian
written in this basis and you can
express it this way it's essentially a
factorization of the Hamiltonian which
expresses the hard part the Coulomb
operator as a sum of n different
diagonal operators each in a rotated
single particle basis and
if you write the Hamiltonian like this
it's apparent that you can do Trotter
steps and only ndepth by first applying
the basis rotation then applying this
diagonal part and then applying the
basis rotation again and just sort of
repeating that for each of these
different bases of which there are N and
that just comes from sort of some
structure in the Coulomb operator that
that factorization ends up being low
right the final thing I'll say about
this and this is specifically what
Brigitta was talking about is that when
you're interested in measuring the
energy of the Hamiltonian which is
something you want to do in a broad
number of contexts so for instance this
is required in garnet sky dive rhythm
even though that's not a variational
algorithm one of the most effective ways
to do that is to first apply this basis
rotation and then sample these terms
which are diagonal and you know do that
for each of the different bases and the
reason why that's a good idea is because
it reduces the variance of these
operators it means there's many fewer
circuits that you need to sample in
order to estimate the energy and all of
your your energy estimates end up being
diagonal which has the advantage of
commuting with the particle number
operator and that means that you can
simultaneously post select on states
that have the correct particle number so
that can also be an effective form of
air mitigation so anyways all of these
things require basis rotations they show
up everywhere they show up for the
Hubbard model too so it's it's in
general a pretty important primitive all
right so how do we actually realize
these basis rotations on a quantum
computer so we had a PRL about this a
couple of years back but again this is
the operator we want to apply this sort
of arbitrary free Fermi on evolution now
you might think oh we should just
trotter eyes this but it turns out that
because this these one body operators
have a closed Lee algebra there's sort
of a nice way of applying it that's
exact and doesn't require any Trotter
ization and in particular if we are
going to apply this to a state that's
1/2 filling which is what we're going to
be doing in our experiment we end up
with a circuit that has a structure that
looks just like this
so it's something which you can apply on
even a linear array of qubits so you
need just minimal connectivity to do it
and each of these two qubit operations
here corresponds to a so called Gibbons
rotation so it's an it's an operation
that looks
thing like this and the idea is that you
sort of figure out what these Thetas are
by this procedure where you apply a
sequence of the rotations that look like
this to the Kappa matrix in order to
diagonalize it which is sort of just a
complicated way of saying the value of
theta here is some function of the Kappa
in this expression which you can
evaluate classically of course this is
not a native to qubit operation on our
device but we can realize it with some
gates that are in particular two
repetitions of the square root I swap
gate that's a gate that we have on our
hardware and some single qubit Z
rotations will implement this operation
okay so the last thing before I really
get into some you know results from the
experiment here is I also want to
explain that this choice of variational
on sots it also somewhat simplifies the
implementation of the variational
algorithm and it does that in a couple
different ways one of the ways
corresponds to needing to make fewer
measurements so usually we would have to
estimate you know the energy of the
Hamiltonian by sampling all of the terms
in this expression here and of course
these two body terms of which there are
end of the for those tend to be the most
problematic I'll introduce a little bit
of notation here where we think about
you know all of these PQ expectation
values as as a matrix so this you know
we just collect these expectation values
and do an N by n matrix so that would be
called the one-particle reduced density
matrix or one RDM and all of these
expectation values organized into a
matrix they'd be called the two particle
reduced density matrix or two RDM so it
turns out that because this hartree-fock
state that we're producing is a mean
field state the two RDM can be
completely you can obtain it through
cumulant construction from the one RDM
using the expression that i've written
down here so in other words you actually
only need to measure the one artyom for
this experiment in order to completely
determine the energy and that means that
drastically drastically simplifies the
number of measurements that we have to
make for the experiment I should also
mention that these rtems that we measure
they have certain known structure and
some of these are sort of straw
sure that will apply even for a
completely arbitrary quantum chemistry
on thoughts for instance the trace of
the one RDM needs to equal the number of
electrons in the system which is just a
way of saying that the wavefunction
needs to have support entirely
uncomplicated states that you know have
a number of ones that's equal to the
number of electrons which is kind of
obvious from the encoding but there are
some other properties that apply in this
context to for instance the one RDM
needs to be positive semi-definite
that's actually always true but it also
needs to be idempotent and this allows
for a form of err mitigation where we
can actually purify the one RDMs that we
obtain and so what I mean by this is we
obtain some estimate of the one RDM from
the kalam computer but say there's some
noise in it maybe we didn't make enough
measurements or something like this so
it's possible to project that one RDM to
the nearest one RDM which is consistent
with having come from a pure state and
there's an efficient procedure for doing
that and so that's a form of error
mitigation that we're able to use in
this experiment now the particular form
that we use which is called McWeeny
purification that applies only to wave
on sauce of the form that we're studying
here however more generally there are
known conditions on the two Artyom's
that would apply in the totally general
context for variational algorithms for
chemistry which are conditions which
must hold only for peer to RDMs
and so you know in principle there are
versions of this that would apply more
generally as well oh we don't need them
here why instead of just doing a
singularity composition
oh there you could do that too
ultimately it's just a way for restoring
idempotency so it's the same result okay
so I should probably say something about
the hardware platform rep before getting
into the data here so this is a picture
of our Sycamore processor it has 54
planar trans bond qubits you can't
really see the qubits because we make
the qubits on one chip and we make the
wiring on another and we kind of solder
them together and this thing's already
flipped over so you can't see the qubits
here here's a picture of our
refrigerator with our CEO standing in
front for scale so the thing that we're
sort of most proud about this device is
the air rates so jared mentioned this
yesterday but this is a schematic of
what the chip looks like the x's of the
qubits and the boxes are the couplers
between the qubits and here we're
showing the air weight distribution
across the chip but we have less than 1%
air and the one in two qubit gates even
when they're implemented in parallel
across the entire chip on average the
readout air is hovering around 4% which
is something that we we can certainly
improve and we're working to improve it
but especially when the goal is to
measure expectation values as we're
doing here readout air is not so much of
a problem because you know usually
what's happening is you have T 1 DK
during readout so that means that some
percent of the time when you measure a0
was really a 1 but it's very easy just
to do a calibration to tell you know if
I know that 4 percent of the time I
measured a 0 is really a one you can
just factor that and your estimate the
expectation value and it's not such a
big deal we should say that most of the
data for this experiment was collected
through a cloud interface to the device
which our team is fish fooding that
means you know it's before dog food
we're sort of testing it out before we
release this to the public but we use
circ to control the kalam computer and
we use to open fermion for all of the
chemistry related parts of the
calculation all right so with that how
well does the machine actually do I
should probably first day you know what
did we actually do so we did a couple
things one of them is we made more of
these curves hooray but this time it's
not just for you know
molecular hydrogen with two hydrogen's
but we actually looked at a series of
different hydrogen chains and we did h
6h h 10 h 12 and so of course h 12
that's not a real molecule but this is a
very simple benchmark it's a nice
benchmark as you stretch it you kind of
you know scale the system between
regimes of strong and weak correlation
and we're sort of not obscuring what
we're doing in some weird way here and
you know doing three electrons and
calling it benzene or something it's
just you know what you see is what you
get so we thought this was a good
benchmark and we'll I'll show you those
results the other thing is you know
we're all a little bit tired of doing
these diatomics so we wanted to do some
example of a system that really felt
like you were doing chemistry and in
particular what I meant by that is
you're actually trying to resolve the
correct chemical reaction mechanism for
some system so we focused on the dyzee
nice ah memorization so dicing is it's
basically hydrogen peroxide both
nitrogen's instead of the oxygens and
you know can be in a configuration like
this or like that and it's rigid because
as a double bond it can't just you know
spin over easily but it can isomerize
between the two and it can do that by
going like this where this guy moves you
know out of the plane or it can go like
that where it moves in the plane and
there are two different mechanisms for
that and you know you have to compute
the energy surfaces and you have to see
which one you know has the the lower
energy energy surface in order to
resolve the reaction mechanism so we
wanted to see if we could do this at
least within the model chemistry that
we're studying which is hardly welcome
okay so first I'll talk about the
hydrogen chain benchmarks again for
something like h6 we have a circuit that
would look like this I should say that
you know then no often you think age six
is twelve electrons for us it's I mean
twelve qubits it's only six cubits for
us and that's because of the fact that
we're focusing our hartree-fock it
allows us to just focus on you know just
all the up spin electrons or something
like this so anyways this is the curve
that we obtained for h6 both of this
data is shown after variational
optimization the green dots are
for we apply air mitigation and the blue
dots are afterwards the air mitigation
again corresponds to post selection on
particle number and this McWeeny
purification procedure and so I should
say this is six cubits it's already this
is already on par with the biggest I
mean the biggest previous chemistry
experiments have been six cubits this is
already about the scale perhaps bigger
than the biggest ones previously but we
also did H 8 and H 10 and H 12 so this
is now you know well over I think it's
something like five times the number of
gates is the largest prior experiments
and double the number of qubits and you
know at least qualitatively we have
pretty good accuracy here it's not
perfect chemical accuracy but none of
the results that six cubits were either
I mean this certainly highlights some of
the challenges of doing chemistry and
the nasarah obtaining this very high
level precision is quite challenging but
you know overall we're getting good
qualitative agreement and that's you
know that's something I think it's quite
positive hartree-fock yeah so we're
doing this relative to the model
chemistry indeed if you were comparing
this to I mean it's I think this is kind
of the proper comparison to because you
know sometimes people will put the FCI
curve there but of course that's just
the FCI curve within the basis you know
it FCI would be the exact
diagonalization within the basis but you
know that's still within a model
chemistry it's within a basis
well we'll get to that in a second so
this is just the bond binding curve
there's no reaction right here but we'll
talk about that with daizen in a moment
so the number of gates is N squared over
2 well sorry that's the number of two
cubed gates and then there's four gates
per so it's 2n squared is essentially
the number of gates but I've written out
the number of gates here too so it's 18
square root I swaps in 27 our Z's maybe
that's an easier way of doing it this
one's 72 square root I swap sin 108 are
diseased the green one is with is what
we get before air mitigation so before
this post-election on particle number
and the purification from here but there
are air bars on there right there are
air bars on here there are they're very
small yeah we did enough measurements
yeah maybe that screens higher
resolution are you to be the know the so
it's actually that's a good question so
I'm not gonna click all the way back to
that slide but um okay so the number of
parameters is if you look in here it's
sort of like the number of parameters
that appear in here and there's a couple
symmetries that reduce it even further
but the our Z's are sort of a function
of what these Kappas are and there's
actually fewer variational parameters
than there are our Z's well I don't
recall exactly but 27 our Z's I think
it's probably on the order of I think
it's a little bit less than half
probably so you know there's probably
about 50 variational parameters here
maybe like 12 here roughly
so that's a good question I mean yes
there there can be but the results that
we're showing here like the the
procedure is not to just sort of run it
until you get the results that you like
usually when we have variation between
the runs we try to figure out why it is
and often you know we figure out
something like oh the AC was turning on
and off in the room during this run or
that actually was something we noticed
how big that's so that should be I mean
it's worth mentioning that many of these
points they consist of hundreds of
thousands of measurements each of these
points which are averaged over which
which are not even like that those are
collected over a period of time that's
long enough to see effects from things
like one over F noise so I don't think
that in general you'll see much
fluctuation from that
so I mean okay so we're we're applying
our circuit were and then we're sort of
sampling these things that correspond to
the energy and we're performing the
variational optimization which which
I'll show the data for here so the I
mean there's probably some fluctuation
in the way that the variational
optimization performs in some cases it
may take more iterations than in others
but ultimately we I mean we I think that
we will converge to the same point
is the retraction back to the manifold
done classically yes wrapping through
the calculation starting from once like
are you using parameters through a
previous execution as a starting point
or are you using a consistent starting
point throughout or random we're
starting in the atomic orbital basis
they're not really computed they're sort
of just a function of the basis set that
you use so it's like whenever you're
using hydrogen you know that you're
taking these you know you have gouge and
center to hydrogen that look like this
then there's a procedure that's like
Graham orthogonalization to make sure
that the orbitals are orthogonal and
that's what we use but they're not
optimized in any way for the molecule
that's where the hartree-fock procedure
is doing this black curve this is the
hartree-fock energy the set of basis
states you have yes it's an exactly the
same dimension as yes yeah although that
solution is actually only dependent on
the number of primitive basis functions
of which we're using many so as you add
like number of qubits the black curve
doesn't move it will always be the same
because our epoch only in the real world
how far down is
you know in the experiments if you used
to like the continuum basis and you did
FCI I don't know
it does look differently though but I
mean that's not accessible to our
experiment so we're not comparing to it
all right so here I'm showing some of
the traces from the variational
optimization so I want to point out that
this is on a log scale on the y axis so
okay so we're getting convergence here
across 1.5 decades which I think kind of
speaks to this question that I was being
asked about a moment ago regarding
what's the convergence of the procedure
and you know sort of strength in some of
our conviction that you know were
actually converging to these points I
mean you can't go lower than this energy
and you know we do tend to get to this
point so this is also another reason why
I think that it's reasonable to suspect
that you know the experiments run
tomorrow are gonna look the same even
without any optimization
yeah I mean so the reason for that would
be because we're starting in an atomic
orbital basis and so the further away
you are the more treating the orbitals
like they're on individual atoms and
they're not bonding the better that
approximation is I would think yeah
because that still doesn't look like a
point of the state in the atomic that's
still very fun space it's your monitor
orbit where the default guess what
so yeah I mean this is still well
outside chemical accuracy though yeah
anyways yeah I think we're just starting
in the atomic orbital basis so I'm not
yeah so in any event I also want to
point out that the optimization
procedure we use it's sort of a Newton
Rapson procedure that we cooked up but
it's also using gradient information
which we're able to obtain from the 1r
DM which is sort of a nice property
again of the hartree-fock on sots that
we're looking at so I also here we've
broken out this is just for h6 by the
way here we've broken out some of the
different contributions to the air so I
believe that this is the curve before
we've applied the post-selection
this is the curve after we've applied
the purification and then this is the
curve that it comes after the
variational optimization and so to some
extent very loosely you could think
about these three procedures as
correcting different types of air this
one correcting essentially t1 air
because it's just restoring the particle
number to what it should be this one
correcting t2 air and this one adjusting
for coherent airs or control errors okay
so finally here is our dicing curve
which frankly we are still working on I
mean I expect it will improve some
before we actually publish this paper
but before David was asking about you
know what the correspondence is between
the you know actual dicing curve and FCI
and what it is in hartree-fock and you
know in hartree-fock it it doesn't look
great it has some cusp here that's yours
result of the calculation being
hartree-fock but again the point here is
just to sort of study convergence to the
model chemistry so you know how well are
we doing here you know we're doing okay
we're actually able to correctly resolve
what the transition state is within the
model chemistry but you know indeed it
would be good to see these values
improve so anyways that was that was all
the data I planned to show
what what did we actually do what did we
learn in this experiment well the first
comment is we realized what is by far
the largest misc qualm chemistry
experiments you know larger than or it's
it's twice the size of the largest prior
ones but quite frankly is you know you
all have seen I I think that there are
some real challenges here I think it's
very unlikely that we're going to you
know be able to have similar results
that would scale past about 20 cubits
unless the error rates improved very
substantially and I don't think that
they will so to some extent I I think
that just sort of refinements of the
paradigm methods that we're already
using may not be enough I think that we
may need some you know fairly big ideas
to go beyond this or you know a couple
sort of big breakthroughs in the way
we're thinking about things like error
mitigation but that's okay I mean at
least that we sort of know where we
stand with things today so again the on
sauce that we looked at it corresponded
to arbitrary free Fermi on evolution
which when optimized gives you the
hartree-fock solution which is you know
in some sense if you're just coming from
the kalam chemistry world you might the
first thing you might want to ask is how
well does the thing do on hartree-fock
and again this is a primitive that comes
up all over quantum algorithms for
chemistry so it's one that you know
independently of this experiment we
think that we'd want to be able to do
quite well we did see the algorithm
performance improve quite a lot due to
error mitigation procedures such as post
selection this purification on the RDM
and variational feedback but like I say
still you know I think we have a long
ways to go before we're doing anything
classically intractable in the nist crew
team we're perhaps we're just going to
need to wait for error correction which
it was a possibility as well so with
that i want to thank first of all the
whole google team you know this is a new
chip that was we accessed largely
through a cloud interface and that took
an enormous team effort to support but i
also especially want to thank Nick Rubin
whose picture is up there on the right
Nick actually designed and led much of
this experiment you might have the
answer about why that atomicorbital
starting point looked so good
also Charles Neil on the hardware team
who helped sort of run the experiment
and get to the bottom of some of these
issues like is the a/c on or not and
then Zhang Jiang and Vadim smelly on ski
we're also quite helpful for sort of
helping with techniques for calibrating
the device and improving control and
this sort of thing so maybe one or two
quick questions
[Music]
yeah
so I frankly the number of measurements
required I think actually adding
correlation to beyond sots is going to
be extremely straightforward in fact
we're already sort of working on it
basically in that circuit that I've
shown that's generated just by xx and YY
terms if you add a generator that has
some Z Z component which would require
one more entangling operation and two
more single qubit operations in each of
those you know two qubit gates we're
realizing so to increase the gates by
50% but have a circuit looked the same
structure then you have something which
would be classically intractable too
well you know if scaled up it's it's not
hard to [ __ ] it's something that has a
lot of correlation in it and we have
some ideas about how to get good
parameters for that
generalize her based on particle number
sure yeah so preparing like fermionic
option states yeah so that's something
else that we could have done actually
we're working on another experiment
that's about the hubbard model where we
do prepare a BCS state which is an
example of this we could have done that
so for chemistry it's kind of a nuanced
thing because you know that the correct
ground states supposed to have certain
symmetries but in practice you can get
lower energies often by breaking those
symmetries that's especially true
because we're in a smaller basis this is
kind of like a basis artifact thing so
we could have done that and that
probably would have been interesting the
fact that you break those symmetries
though makes some of the air mitigation
procedures we're using less effective
because you can no longer post select on
spin and particle number
[Applause]